hello everyone and welcome back to the
chest 24 legends tournament uh legends
of chess tournament it's
magnus carlsen vs vladimir kramnik and
we are going to show the third game of
their match game one ended in a draw
here on the position you see a position
from their second game which is
extremely interesting
uh but it's actually magnus with the
black pieces i the photos are as they
are because that's for the third game uh
but i want you to
to see what happened in the second game
as magnus
magnus was able to trick vladimir into
uh
well just losing these two pawns so here
magnus
magnus played queen to f2 check and uh
vladimir has to go king to h3 and here
uh sorry about that uh here uh he would
have to settle for a perpetual check for
example here here here here
check check check and that's it however
after this queen f2 check
vladimir blocked with the queen and here
we have
uh bishop captures on g3 with check this
is how magnus wins both of the pawns
king h3 queen captures king captures and
now just bishop captures on h8 but not
right away first there was a rook trait
captures captures and the bishop
captures on h4
and now we're in an end game where
magnus is up to pawns uh the problem is
this is a completely drawn end game and
uh
but you need to play it uh precisely
here vladimir went for knight to e6 but
there is
there is a much better move or rather a
series of moves
so uh feel free to pause the video and
try to figure it out while i give you a
couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations as you've
found the move that vladimir missed but
also very interestingly
you did polgar spotted it like instantly
during the live coverage so it's
knight to f7 check king has to go to g8
and now knight the h6 check
point being that if the pawn captures
the knight now it's the the h pawn is of
the wrong color you can just hide the
king into a light square corner and the
dark square bishop of course will not be
able to help
and it doesn't matter if you don't
capture the knight if king here or here
uh then just knight to f5 attacks the
bishop and that's it once the bishop
moves wherever it doesn't really matter
you're just gonna sacrifice the knight
for the g pawn
and again the h pawn is of the wrong
color and easy draw
uh vladimir missed this but in the end
he was able to to somehow get a draw
anyway as uh well obviously this is much
harder to win
uh then it looks like uh even though you
are up two pawns
uh so game two also ended in a draw and
then we have the game three the game
which we are actually showing now magnus
is white vladimir is black
uh and uh let's check it out so magnus
opens with the d4 and we're gonna
have a nice queens gambit declined so
knight f6
c4 e6 we have knight to c3 and d5 so the
queen's gambit declined is on the board
uh we have c captures e captures and of
course bishop g5
something magnus goes for very often we
have c6 uh strengthening the d5 pawn and
e3 now preparing to develop the light
square bishop with h6 pushing the bishop
back
bishop to h4 and bishop to d3 now so
very
standard the developing moves uh first
bishop e7 and then bishop d3
uh very standard developing moves by
both of them now we have castles by
kramnik
and knight g to e2 by magnus rook to e8
and now
castles by magnus and knight the h5 now
offering a trade of bishops here
we have bishop captures queen captures
and now there is one game in the
database where rook the b1 was played
but here magnus goes queen to d2
and it is a new move in the position so
already as of move 12 we have a
completely new game
seems a bit odd not placing the queen to
c2 or on b3
uh but uh magnus probably wants to use
it uh later on as means of maybe
something like this f3 e4
and maybe after e4 is played so the
queen adds additional protection to
the e5 pawn and also might be to the f4
square uh the queen to d2 is a mystery
to me
uh but okay knights to d7 and now rook 8
to e1
continuing with with the development and
now knight to f8 the knight will now
serve as a nice defender here also later
you can shift it to g6 or e6
uh depending on what magnus plays so
knight the c1
and now preparing to push push the pawn
to f3 and then grab e4 later on
knight back to f6 by kramnik and now f3
just uh preparing this uh e4 thrust in
the center so 96
uh and now with this knight here uh the
d4 pawn could become a bit vulnerable
when e4 is played so queen here might be
used for that also if you shift it to f2
the queen will nicely be defending the
d4 pawn as well
so knight e to the knight uh one to e2
shifting the knight over to g3 and the
b5 now by kramnik and here magnus went
into
a little thing of course you have to see
what happens if b4 is played
but he just goes knights to g3 he frees
up the e2 square for this knight
if needed and uh kramny just continues
expanding on the queen side with a5
and something i forgot to mention uh
this is the last uh
match of the preliminaries after this
they go into into the finals of the
chess 24 legends tournament
and the kramnik needs a win against
magnus to qualify for the
for the finals so queen f2 by magnus
and bishop to a6 now preparing some b
for ideas uh in in in the future
with knight f5 by magnus attacking the
queen queen back to d8 and now
knight to e2 preparing to shift the
other knight over to the king set as
well also b4 was kind of an
idea here and c5 now striking in the
center
as a magnus allowed it uh or or did he
here magnus goes queen to g3 and already
there are some threats here okay
g7 is defended for the moment but if
this knight ever moves it could be very
tricky
for example if you try something like
kinked also knight captures on h6 is a
threat because the g pawn is pinned so
if something like this
knight f4 is coming and then you just
attack the defender of the g7 square and
it's
uh well black will lose this position
so here after queen to g3 with c4
attacking carlson's bishop now kind of
trying to bait a knight captures an h6
with check so after the king moves both
pieces would be under attack
but magnus calmly just moves the bishop
bishop to c2
and now knight to h5 attacking the queen
queen to h3 here a knight captures an h6
was also a possibility king of f8 and
only then queen to h3
if captures them captures you win a nice
pawn however
magnus prefers to keep the tension queen
h3 just goes after the knight
right away and now uh kramnik should
just repeat
knight to f6 and just uh wait to wait
for carlsen to repeat queen g3 knight
stage 5 and so on and then magnus would
probably go for this knight captures an
h6 idea
but kramnik decides to avoid this
entirely and just goes g6 he gives up
the h6 pawn
and allows magnus well to get some more
pieces into the game so knight captures
an h6 with
check king g7 and now knight back to f5
with check saying okay if captures then
i can just capture here
uh king back to g8 and now comes knight
eat the g3
again if you capture here then this
knight gets captured
so we have knight uh captures on g3 like
this but now
queen captures now the g pawn is pinned
so you cannot capture
uh and here kramnik should have gone for
something like queen to g5
or for the queen trade or something in
in those lines but he went for b4
instead
preparing this c3 idea opening up an
attack on the rook
uh but now uh it's uh it's actually a
winning position for magnus so feel free
to pause the video and
find the winning uh winning idea while i
give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on spotting that
the f7 pawn is
actually defending the g6 pawn and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's
knight the h6 check now you fork the
king and the defender of this pawn
so king g7 and the magnus just
eliminates it captures king captures and
bishop captures grabbing two pawns
uh and a rook uh for two pieces so king
is seven
and the bishop captures on e8 we have
king captures uh sorry uh king captures
and
now comes uh e4 striking in the center
you want to open up the
uh the files for these rooks and now
okay kramnik does have a knight and a
bishop
for a rook but his pieces are very uh
discoordinated and the magnus is
up three pawns so that's also something
so c3
kramnik prepares to create a pass pawn
now also opens up an attack on the rook
so rook f2
uh preparing to capture if kramnik
captures
king f7 of course you don't want this
position to open up while your king is
still on e8
so b captures on c3 with b captures and
now
f4 magnus sees that this pawn isn't
really worth anything you want to play
f5
f6 and finish the game so d captures on
e4 and now f5
chasing the knight away you do need to
guard this square so knight here to
prevent queen to g6 check
and now rook captures an e4 magnus just
calmly recaptures
and now the threat is just f6 followed
by rook to e7 which
isn't checkmate but uh just as well
you'd have to give up the queen
so kramnik plays a very tricky move rook
the b8 hoping for
f6 from magnus but then he just has rook
to b1 check rook f1 and rook captures
with checkmate
as the bishop covers this uh square here
uh however magnus spots that he
he does have some back rank issues so he
clears uh the h2 square for his king he
just plays a nice h3 move
there is no rush here i mean the king is
on f7 and
you know uh uh checkmate is coming
so rook the b1 check we have king to h2
and now uh
kramnik spots the queen b8 maneuver to
trade off the queens
uh but it's still going to be a very
hard end game for him so queen captures
rook captures
and now of course rook to e3 going after
the pawn here
there is no good way to defend it if you
go rook to c8 then just
rook to c2 and you will win it either
way it's on a dark square the light
square bishop is
helpless here so bishop c4 uh kramnik
hopes to
shift the bishop over here to to at
least block the the d-pawn
but now magnus just captures we have
bishop to d5 and
rook c5 with a double attack here rook
to d8 defending and now just rook
captures on a5 and still kramnik bishop
and knight against rogue but magnus is
up
five pawns that's uh that's pretty crazy
so rogue d7 by kramnik now g4 the mo the
pawns start uh
marching forward i almost said mons uh
so
knight to h7 and king to g3 this is now
uh
basically uh uh just the the use of
technique which magnus doesn't lack
knight f6 and now rook to c2 preparing
to shift both rooks into the attack rook
e7
and now king to h4 the king is also a
very valuable
valuable attacker in the end game bishop
e4 attacking the rook now rook
b2 uh we have knight to d5 and now king
the g5 and now the h pawn is also
uh free to start marching forward we
have rook d7
and now rook to a6 grabbing more space
for for the white rooks
rook to c7 and now rook to e6
now the other rook will also join the
party knight c3
uh defending the bishop here but now
rook f6 check king g7
rook g6 shock king to f7 and now king to
h6 preparing rook check to
pick up the rook on z7 so rook c8
but now still rook g7 check we have king
to f8 and now
rook to b6 the other rook also joins the
party
uh with bishop to d5 now uh helping out
with
with uh some squares here so you don't
have something like check king moves in
this check easily uh
trading so rook h7 now uh threatening
rook to h8 but now
knight to e4 and now there really isn't
all that much you can do
rook to h8 checked by magnus bishop the
g8 blocking and now uh
rook to g6 just going for a double
attack here on the bishop
king f7 okay now it's defended twice but
now just
rook g7 check uh getting the king away
from the defense of the bishop
king of six and now rook h captures on
g8 and it was
in this position on 62 that vladimir
kramnik resigned the game
and a game three goes to magnus as there
is nothing more to be done here let's
say you trade you are rook against the
knight and the magnus is still up five
pawns
so of course it would be pointless to
continue uh kramnik resigns and the
magnus uh
now only needs a draw in game four to uh
to claim the win in the match and to
be victorious in all of the matches in
the preliminaries of the chess 24
uh legends of chess tournament so yeah
uh that's uh the game i do hope you
enjoyed it uh very very eager to see
what happens in game four
i would like to thank ishmael rivera or
petrovice david kimura christopher
fernandez and
mikhail rudko for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you all for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the chest 24
legends tournament
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day